el momento de conocer las principales
noticias en materia económica de américa
latina y del resto del mundo y es por
eso que nos acompaña por supuesto jorge
hurtado jorge muy buenas noches
comenzamos con la noticia que ayer
empezamos a adelantarnos eeuu finalmente
ordenó la liberación de reservas de
petróleo contános a qué se debe esto
bueno santiago el anuncio estuvo a cargo
del presidente de eeuu joe biden quien
dijo que hizo esto en coordinación con
china india corea del sur japón y reino
unido- la iniciativa de liberar 50
millones de barriles de las reservas
estratégicas de petróleo de su país es
con el fin de intentar enfriar los
precios de los combustibles y después de
que los países productores de petróleo
hayan ignorado las peticiones de
producir más crudo la liberación de las
reservas busca abordar el desajuste
entre la demanda y la oferta de
combustible de cara a la temporada
navideña y bajo la amenaza de la
inflación los 50 millones de barriles
incluyen 32 millones que serán
intercambiados en el mercado en los
próximos meses y otros 18 millones que
ya estaban autorizados para su venta por
el congreso de eeuu
eeuu tiene reservas de petróleo
localizadas en grandes cavernas
subterráneas al sur del país y son
consideradas las más grandes del mundo
ya que rondan los 605 millones de
barriles escuchemos al presidente de
eeuu joe biden
hoy lanzamos un gran esfuerzo para
moderar el precio del petróleo un
esfuerzo que abarcará a todo el mundo y
que si dios quiere llegar a la
gasolinera de su esquina he trabajado
duro estas últimas semanas ha mantenido
llamadas y reuniones con líderes
extranjeros y responsables políticos
para reunir los elementos necesarios
para el anuncio global de hoy y aunque
nuestra acción combinada no resolverá el
problema de los elevados precios de la
gasolina de la noche a la mañana marcará
la diferencia
santiago y es que según la publicación
de bloomberg la decisión se da ante la
negativa de aumentar la producción de
parte de los países miembros de la
organización de países exportadores de
petróleo que es conocida como opep jose
vamos ahora a turquía porque la lira hoy
sufrido una de sus peores caídas
contanos por qué a qué se debe esto
bueno esto se da luego fuertes
declaraciones del presidente de ese país
tayyip erdogán quien defendió los
recientes recortes de los tipos de
interés y prometió ganar lo que él llama
una guerra económica de independencia
pese a las críticas la lira llegó a caer
hasta
13.450 con respecto al dólar tocando
mínimos históricas por undécima sesión
consecutiva en lo que va de este año la
moneda ha perdido el 45 por ciento de su
valor erdogán ha presionado al banco
central para que inicie un agresivo
ciclo de recortes de la tasa de interés
que pretende según él impulsar las
exportaciones la inversión y el empleo
incluso mientras la inflación se ubica
cerca del 20 por ciento allí varios
dueños del negocio salieron a protestar
y quemaron dólares simbólicamente veamos
cuáles son sus impresiones
esa bajada haggard juniors los
comerciantes no pueden dormir y no dejan
de preocuparse por lo que pasará mañana
los alquileres impagados se acumulan la
mercancía no se compra ni se vende nadie
comparte nuestra carga de mi hermano don
el presidente turco declaró enemigo a
los tipos de interés porque según él son
los que provocan aumento de precios
cuando el mundo dice lo contrario de
hecho erdogán sacó a quienes lo
contradicen en el banco central en
septiembre y dejó solamente a personas
afines jorge de turquía hacemos un
larguísimo viaje hasta argentina porque
hay novedades económica de este país
sudamericano verdad así es y tienen que
ver con el crecimiento económico según
un reciente informe oficial el
crecimiento se ubicó en 1,2 por ciento
respecto al último mes
este aumento suma cuatro meses
consecutivos en positivo luego
permanecer estancada durante febrero y
mayo de este año según el reporte de 15
actividades incluidas en el indicador 13
de los sectores productivos muestran
mejoras respecto al año pasado entre
ellas figuran santiago hoteles y
restaurantes la construcción la minería
la industria y el comercio según los
pronósticos de recuperación economía el
gobierno el crecimiento rondaría este
año el 9 por ciento e inicios del
próximo año interno bruto se estaría
recuperando todo lo que perdió durante
la pandemia pero algunos analistas
modelan esas perspectivas mientras
firmas internacionales alertan de que la
crisis política interna podría siendo
afectar la economía bueno quizás un poco
de buenas noticias para una economía tan
castigado vamos con los indicadores de
la jornada que dicen así arrancamos con
walker que cerró mixto por la
permanencia de john powell a cargo del
banco central más importante del mundo
las acciones europeas se desplomaron
hasta un mínimo de tres semanas durante
su mayor pérdida diaria en casi dos
meses producto del temor de los cierres
por comida en europa y en latinoamérica
la bolsa de méxico ganó 1.23 por ciento
gracias a un movimiento correctivo al
alza cerramos con no siempre con la
esperada cifra del día esta vez cuál es
así que es la cifra de 17.000 millones
de dólares esos destinar a samsung en
austin texas para construir una fábrica
que produciría chips a propósito de
estas casas de scripts mundiales gracias
muchísimas gracias por estar
completísima crónica hasta aquí la
información económica enfermas 24 les
recordamos que pueden seguir
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france 24 punto com
sigan con nosotros
[Música]